how to bring your old iPhone back to
life you can't install modern apps on
old iPhones if you need old versions of
apps that are not on app store or
programs that can't be found there at
all only jailbreak will help you access
to file system and app installation from
side sources using iOS mistakes in
addition you'll get access to thousands
of settings and options for your iPhone
or iPad that are usually hidden for
example activator allows the user to
bind various actions to iPhone's
components display accelerometer
switches to start any app turn on the
flashlights or block your smartphone
just shake it or press selected buttons
anything you can imagine you can do this
and a lot more when you install Cydia
App Store equivalents on your phone or
any similar apps remember Apple doesn't
support this operation officially when
you hack your Gadget you'll lose
manufacturer's warranty don't forget
that all apps downloaded are created by
side developers that don't have apple
verification we recommend you to create
a separate Apple ID and do not enter
your banking details